breaking news out of south florida a
deadly partial collapse of an apartment
tower there
shocking video has just come in though
we should warn you we've not been able
to verify
the source of this video but just take a
look at it the footage appears to show
the central part of the building falling
overnight
followed by another section just moments
later
rescuers say they've pulled 35 people
from the building it's in surfside
florida that's just north of miami beach
witnesses say they heard people
screaming and these aerial images show
the scale of the challenge
currently facing rescuers one person has
died and the building manager expects
the death toll to rise
manuel jorgesse is at the scene for us
where a news briefing just ended manny
good morning to you what more do we know
good morning there were at least 55
units that were
impacted by that collapse what is
standing is still behind me right there
the collapse just on the other side as
you mentioned the mayor confirmed to us
at least one fatality
and 10 people have been treated for
their injuries but the fear of course
is those figures could rise and perhaps
significantly
given the extent of the collapse let's
go ahead and show you what is a map
view of what the building looked like
before the collapse
and what it looks like now it is
reminiscent of a
war zone there are dozens of rescuers
right now
combing through the rubble looking for
any survivors
there is a lot yet unknown here as they
continue that search
the building one of these huge buildings
gone
right here beside us the craziest thing
i've ever heard in my life
it's hard to fathom just after 2 a.m
this 12-floor condo building and
surfside suddenly crashing to the ground
yeah i thought it was like a storm or
something coming in and then
when the dust cleared there was the back
half of the building or back
two thirds of the building was gone just
north of miami beach this idyllic
neighborhood is now a disaster zone
the problem is the building has
literally pancaked
there's just feet in between stories
where there were 10 feet
that is is heartbreaking
mayor charles burkett fears finding
survivors alive
may be unlikely as daylight renews the
search and rescue effort that began
overnight
and earlier crews were seen recovering a
young boy from the rubble
what we saw from the beginning was a
huge cloud of smoke
and lots of noise mich balcony and his
brothers
live in surfside they were out taking a
walk when the building collapsed
and they have friends with family
members living there we put our shirts
over our face
so we don't get any like dust in our
eyes and everything and i asked
a security guard from the other building
and she says yeah they were doing
construction over there
what caused the deadly accident is still
unclear but it's not the first time
surfside has seen devastation like this
in 2018 less than 10 minutes down the
street
a 13-story condo collapsed during its
demolition
critically injuring a construction
worker who later died in the hospital
as for this morning some residents
appeared to be trapped on their
balconies in parts of the building that
remained intact
prompting ladder rescues like this one
there's no
reason for this building to go down like
that it's
less likely than the lightning strike
and at this point authorities have not
been able to determine how many people
may have been inside the section of the
building that collapsed here's more of
our
interview with the mayor of surfside
from earlier this morning
what is the latest that you can tell us
about what is known the extent of
casualties here
well i do know that we transported two
people to the hospital according to my
chief this morning
one has died at the hospital
we treated 10 and we have about 15
family units
up at the community center right now and
we're making arrangements for them
to find some housing temporary housing
any idea how many people
are missing right now well
[Music]
there are over 100 units in that
building
and and that's that's what is
frightening us very badly right now
i mean the the back of the building
probably a third or more
is just totally pancaked and you know
we've
you know they did the uh they sent the
dogs in and there were
there were just no hits we had no hits
on the dogs so there were no sounds
and and the dogs did not react so we
were waiting for dave that was in the
middle of the night and
we're waiting now to go back and i think
they're going to do whatever they can do
to try to
find anybody that's alive but the
miami-dade
fire department miami beach these guys
have been incredible they were in that
building
it was potentially going to collapse
looking for people
in the middle of the night which was
astounding to me i mean they risked
their lives to do that
and we owe them a great debt of thanks
unlike south beach this is a mix of
retirees
and families some people leave for the
summer but you're
you're convinced that these were
families who actually live here
full-time yeah
yeah i would say that you know a lot of
families live there full-time now of
course
some come down for the season but uh you
know that that was an active
very filled up building
it's uh you know and we're all just
scratching our heads
trying to imagine what in the world
could have happened
an investigation clearly underway after
the search and rescue mission is
completed here we're trying to put it
together
looks like an earthquake though
looks like an earthquake he says such a
difficult morning here and still
no word on what may have caused the
collapse
a short time ago i spoke with a woman
who had a picture of two men and a
little girl she said
they are her friends from argentina that
they flew to the united states to get
the vaccine
spent some time on the beach she
believes they were in the building and
has not been able
to locate them eureka wow manny pajork
is for us
in surfside with what is clearly a tough
search and rescue operation thank you